boiling point is something that we
normally think of as a stable property
of a substance but it really depends on
what the pressure is around the
substance so for example water only
boils at 100 degrees Celsius if the
pressure is one atmosphere so if you
reduce the pressure then those water
molecules that are going quite quickly
can easily escape from the water if
there's no pressure pushing down on them
so you can get water to boil at room
temperature this is really boiling water
the funny thing about boiling water at
room temperature is that it actually
decreases the temperature of the water
that's because all of the fastest water
molecules escape leaving only the slow
ones behind will refrigerating the water
refrigerate in the water by boiling it
yes yes that is a cool content I know
everyone's a big fan of liquid nitrogen
but I've never seen solid nitrogen so we
use the same trick pumping out the very
fastest nitrogen molecules and
eventually that decreased the
temperature enough that the nitrogen
actually froze
not blue
little bit oh wait SEC what I'm putting
a thermocouple in there so we can
measure the temperature of our liquid
nitrogen and it reads okay so the
temperature of our liquid nitrogen is
about minus 196 Celsius which is exactly
what it should be and now we're going to
evacuate the chain we're going to suck
the air out of there you can see that
the the nitrogen is boiling okay oh yeah
it's a brighter roots the temperatures
dropping
- 199 - 200 we're coming up on the
triple point of nitrogen yeah I don't
know no no maybe not we pass cuckoo
doula oh yeah joy on we are forming
solid nitrogen it has had some pretty
beat
whoa
yeah so you do the ice is actually
getting sucked up by the reduced
pressure up here and there's a higher
pressure underneath the ice because the
vacuum pump hasn't had a chance to work
there I've never seen solid nitrogen
before so don't eat a it Bruce elevator
Lizotte lakita heights on Pluto Angeles
on floater right
he seemed dubious on dessert the decor
shamefully a Zulu ha ha ha cool bro
after creating the solid nitrogen we
poured it onto a water bath and we got
the whole surface so cold that carbon
dioxide actually condensed out of the
atmosphere and we formed solid carbon
dioxide dry ice on the surface of the
water today
prepare a super chip is Easter Sunday
class on Sunday gasps oh hey deputy Fred
50-megaton de armado we go
you sequester on Akshay
so I said you see what do whoa wait
I thought well y'all not know we get for
you okay oh yeah
right yeah about three by three but
Phillip Phillip Phillip Anna oh yeah
does he boo
oh my god Shirley
we have a solid piece of co2 and say
Barbosa
all right Sookie most ridiculous on zero
literally what the court said in a shake
Co the fume in the gutter
I'm Jason
hmm
the propensity para la putana
hexa the world should feel the same way
you dress rehearsal movie slide off tip
of the pencil these are all natural
brains they're usually many matters